vous allez bien bas très bien on est
content de te voir j'ai un jeu ce soir
non qu'est ce que c'est
non je crois pas le bol des imitations à
n'importe quel moment
cyril pourra tirer une boule il devra
imiter le nom qu'il ya dedans si vous le
retrouvez et ben c'est cool et on doit
limiter avoir retrouvé wade à salavaux
sans la boîte sans rien dire et chez
nous il devrait commencer mois
d'hésitations non pas une devinez qui
limite en jeu rappelle france elle même
plus besoin de l'aval entremont
demandera vent mobile voix lorsque jean
pierre foucault jamais été quelqu'un met
au jour
oui moi je suis imitée crise tient à
coeur c'est ça tu vas la chaire ici mais
s'il commet femme et tout le monde est
là et un super plateau moi je passe en
dessous
at your funk bull a connu une petite
boulette attendons qu'on monte que c'est
pas du chiqué
bonjour j'ai préparé le joug aux basses
à l'artiste basse elle est à toi je suis
là dit dur mais c'est aux rentiers le
rire un peu fort c'est quand même très
douloureux c'est à dire ok alors c'est
du temps les stocks
c'est quoi ces mots tu veux faire une
petite mairie de jouer tes boules qui
veut que je fasse une boule à
l'intérieur je répète vous nous
rejoignez il ya un nom ouais voilà cyril
tir et doit imiter le nom le premier qui
trouve gagne du surimi le jambon de la
mer alors les chérit les chérissez à
quelqu'un qui trouve en moins de 10
secondes
je voulais joffre j'offre un ensemble hi
tech
grâce à paris sportifs à quelqu'un sur
twitter d'accord vous mettez à ce tag
aaa attaques des pmp et vous partez avec
un ensemble à la main j'adore serait vu
les dotations
je suis très content d
c'est un jeu revienne qu'aux chino art
et moi je suis revenue mais main devant
une main derrière je voulais dire cyril
hanouna a été d'une générosité
incroyable je vais bientôt avoir la ward
du meilleur juive du yom estime il m'a
sorti saint geours enrico il m'a dit je
te jure que c'est vrai je suis là tu as
là je suis avec lui à la radio et il me
dit syrie juin winehouse à new york
tout est vrai on embrasse très peur de
gagner trois sets l'adorent